[Music]
worth it one stop we're in Nagoya Japan
and that is the Nagoya castle is
actually lit right now and we are with
my best friend remit money okay I think
it works like this she's your best
friend but I'm her best friend oh that
one hurt and you're here with us because
we're doing an awesome spectacular
episode on custom Japanese candy we call
it king cuddle up man he thought always
japanese folk tale character
traditionally the candy has quintero
face on it
the process is extremely satisfying
that's what really what we're here for
is not too many spoilers but we do have
a very special design we're not gonna
give it away right now
that's right you're not gonna see
Quintero in our candy you're gonna see
somebody else
oh man the wind is crazy also there are
crows Kakao II really say in Japanese so
we got some caucus I'm going on right
now let's do it all right do it
[Music]
just about the disciple for you must
Miami Corvo not performed much I want it
for us
customer Gandhi unifying mr. got better
like in math we sent in our own design
to make our special custom candy spoil
alert the design is of our co-producer
Adam Bianchi is we thought it would be a
good design because there's lots of
complications about his face and when
you have this facial hair here the
glasses sometimes nitsana move on okay
focused oh god I don't talk on the phone
down that's pretty a thing okay
Connolly's man can go with a nice yes
amar Tony I'm sharpening toe designer
toe says oh come on man be doing cardio
no can customize Jonas I'm Anita
bakunawa no no no come here mean of them
Karina said ìno percent of Arizona
because I got a Masucci
again Panama robbery today say oh by a
makeover nor a mess opening this country
Sangha foodie so the theme of Oakland
some damage so how do you make the candy
mafia to love is the total is almost a
nice day Nesmith
yacouba's a very not pacified they
cannot legally bound to you Mon Ami are
today is Hamas Onaga polio as its Kato
a family the world for pukara a palpable
architectural statement this local
economy it's the a solid or a definite
no leader I actually do nowadays
solution in parcel to de Vaca T bikini
ad dollars to consider how is each part
of Adams face made muscle
same time the year Putin if at all [ __ ]
with a very character to do to get a
patent balances me oxygen balance to
record it will eat what up here called
Asterix Giamatti us women mother Titan
II killed skatripper
day
Jen Bunney Kato make an ANOVA como
Muppet or even Dabney Kagame offend a
mother supportive korekado Mario Sanka
coffie pavlovskiy offend sko friggin Oh
Sato stop en k Diane Keaton was sweet
children of a swivel rock kills jennifer
freeman llamo Guillermo Ruez record mo
cat aqui aqui para learning of a new
terminal 2 opened a school or starting
work a toccata they cut it off from
arsenal of students so what are you
doing to help make these shapes and keep
everything even during the process do
you know polymer units Caza cartel -
affirmative
sugar coconut sorbet oh no this is gonna
be a very ugly version of Adam I'm sorry
can I cut so do you want to do it Andrew
cool
I noticed that there's a lot of people
working together on this
what's the importance of doing
everything by hand couple young guys
it's criminally takuya under it so you
go to r21 this ghetto sort of a biggie
rhetoric in what articles and I in this
kit will typically don't use up too much
on kick I did quite proper situated in
the kicking on this kit was real job as
you think I like this name we got some
candy
so not only did we see the can to get
made we got to get our hands in the mix
and we did not do a good job we did
probably the least challenging bars yes
so we just lived this moment but I
wanted to call your attention again
oh man says that it's weird because Adam
is holding the camera and filming me
show him this it's it's very hard like
this can be a murder weapon and clue and
then it tapers off into this little tail
in where you get candy Adam Rhea what do
you think about this Coco Co V which is
a ghost has a long neck and they're
coming at you
we'll be a little loopy Adam Adam
Bianchi like the level of sculpture
happening here is really amazing the
candy we're gonna put this away because
I please it's too much to look at we
should bring on the ones that we made
first sure you know just to be clear we
made fifty pounds of candy about 3500
pieces of Adams I believe these are the
ones that we this is like if you took
Adam and put my hair on him yours are
too thin and then some of mine were too
thick so when it got in the rolling
machine that the edge of it just sliced
across his face look at that guy
it's look it looks like you're about to
go into a time warp and you like frozen
and then your body starts swirling in
space hey some of them are pretty good
though if you peek we're not a random
okay it's gonna be awesome
watch this watch this all right you
ready yeah this isn't the 50 pounds
there's many boxes of this oh man so
because these ones are good to go
they're actually individually wrapped
which is great oh yeah he's much
chunkier in the right size one he's got
a much chubbier face which I liked I
think the word is chiseled look at that
one that's it good Adam I mean it really
looks hand-painted right it's like a
single hair paintbrush all right I'm
gonna eat this now here's
you chew it immediately
hahaha hard candies diva grape flavor
huge milk what I like about it is that
it's also not insanely sweet which was
what I was expecting when I saw them
make it no it was a right-side up the
light outline around his ears is
potentially the most impressive to me
the different portions of his face is
all the different rates pretty soon he
could feel this texture of his face
against your tongue and I'm have like
the little bumps at the outline of the
of the eyes yeah I'm licking his eyes
right now you're making it really weird
yeah it was just surprising how good
this candy turns out what's that
supposed to mean
oh yes